Катерина почала шити екоторбинки 2 роки тому.
Її батько продавав поліетиленові пакети, тому вдома їх завжди була незліченна кількість.
Однак згодом Катю почала бентежити звичка бездумного одноразового
використання пластику.
Коли я виходжу у світ і бачу, як люди кладуть один лимон в пакет,
потім ще в один пакет, для мене це просто… Я дуже засмучуюсь.
Дівчина надихнулася ідеєю створити більш екологічну креативну альтернативу
пластиковим пакетам - і запустила домашнє виробництво торбинок з тканини.
Зараз так, є, звісно, попит. Раніше брали 1-2, тепер беруть по п'ять наборів.
Розлітаються, можна сказати…
Попит на екологічніші альтернативи пластиковим пакетам в Україні, судячи з усього, зростатиме.
Адже з 10 грудня починає впроваджуватися законопроєкт "Про обмеження обігу
пластикових пакетів на території України".
Перший етап передбачає, що у закладах торгівлі й громадського харчування
мають зникнути безкоштовні поліетиленові пакети - відтепер за них
доведеться платити. Щоправда, скільки вони коштуватимуть - досі невідомо.
Адже Кабмін досі так і не спромігся затвердити постанову, де був би прописаний
механізм встановлення ціни на пакети залежно від їхньої товщини.
Підприємці цим вкрай спантеличені. У супермаркетах, до яких звернулася DW,
відповіли, що з 10 грудня в них нічого не зміниться. Менеджери досі не знають,
яким чином здійснювати продаж пакетів, за якою ціною та як робити облік
і звітування по касових апаратах.
А що покупці? Чи готові вони платити за поліетиленові пакети?
Значить щось не буду купувати. Продукти. Я ще раз кажу - це не мій клопіт.
Напевно не буду платити. Буду щось придумувати, як наші бабусі шили,
у моєї бабусі була ось така торбинка з тканини. Будемо якось обходитися.
Бо це треба замінити, щоб наша планета була здорова.
Я вважаю, що це дуже корисно, замінити такі пакети, оскільки я сама працюю  двірником,
і це сміття нашій екології дуже заважає.
Я вже замінила на таку сумочку і бажаю це замінити всім.
Буду платити гроші. А що ж робити? Без пакета ж неможливо, ну ось як?
Прийду брати яблука, як можна? Пакетики нам потрібні.
Залюбки б використовувала, якби були, паперові чи ті, які можна викидати.
Бо дуже сильно поліетилен довкілля захаращує.
Очільниця департаменту з питань поводження з відходами міністерства довкілля
Олена Колтик була однією з ініціаторів закону. Вона вважає, що Україна
пасе задніх з такою ініціативою, якщо порівнювати її з Європою.
Приміром, середньостатистичний німець використовує 70 пластикових пакетів на рік,
а українець - близько 500. Однак на думку представниці міндовкілля,
навіть такий запізнілий крок все одно надважливий.
Фактично, це є перша стадія управління відходами, коли ми приймаємо всі необхідні дії,
щоб потім не утворювалося відходів. Цей закон насправді не про відходи пластикових пакетів.
Це про те, щоб ми зменшили їхнє виробництво, зменшили їхнє поширення
і в подальшому мали меншу проблему з їхньою переробкою й утилізацію.
Другий етап закону передбачає, що з 9 березня 2022 року пластикові пакети,
які в народі називають "маєчки", а також цупкі пакети, які продають на касах,
до 50 мікрон, будуть повністю заборонені.
Але, на переконання Європейської Бізнес Асоціації, для цього необхідно встановити
триваліший перехідних період та прописати чіткий механізм впровадження,
аби бізнес розумів, яким правилам слідувати та на які екологічніші альтернативи
вони мають перейти. Такі альтернативи вже виготовляються навіть в Україні.
Приміром, Михайло Грод рік тому заснував підприємство, що виробляє пакети
з крохмалю модифікованої кукурудзи. Окрім крохмалю, у гранули для виробництва
таких пакетів додають полімолочні кислоти й мінерали. Завдяки такій формулі,
пакети не шкодять довкіллю, стверджує Михайло.
Вони розкладаються за 90 днів у компості. Ці пакети, так би мовити, виходять з землі,
тобто з кукурудзи, потім перегнивають, перетворюються на компост
і також потраплять в землю. Циклічна економіка.
Пакети розкладаються за 3 місяці в компостному середовищі
і за рік на звичайному звалищі, стверджують виробники.
Однак інноваційність технології й сировини впливає на ціну.
Сама сировина дорожча, ніж поліетиленова гранула - в три рази.
Це єдине і основне, що так кардинально впливає на ціну - це сировина.
Воно екологічне, нове і, звісно, дорожче.
Щоправда, і такі пакети не можна назвати повністю екологічними,
оскільки для вирощування кукурудзи для сировини використовують
хімічні добрива й пестициди, це теж сприяє викидам СО2.
Як і виробництво бавовни для торбинок з тканини. Тим не менше Катерина Суховієнко впевнена,
що її невелике виробництво формує тренд. І показує, що відмовлятися
від одноразового використання пластику - це круто.
Я підсадила. Ось знаєте як - люди очікують на новий айфон, а у мене люди чекають нових мішечків.
Це заразно. Якщо ви візьмете людину, яка ніколи не користувалася мішечками,
дасте їй п'ять мішечків, вона вперше піде додому з мінімальною кількістю
пластикових пакетів. І потім уже їй буде соромно. Ми всі бували в таких ситуаціях,
коли забув мішечок в машині чи в рюкзаку. І все, у тебе вже дилема.
Катерина рада, що Україна робить перший крок до відмови від пластику.
Але також переконана, що зміни мають відбутися насамперед у свідомості українців,
у їхніх звичках. Коли люди почнуть відмовлятися від пластику з переконання,
а не тому, що їм це забороняє держава.